and vice president kamala harris still
has no plans to head back to the
southern border but she is committed to
jetting off to europe next month joe
contra fox news contributor here to
discuss her lack of engagement as the
migrant crisis grows by the day joe
looks like carmel is working on that old
bucket list remember this
you have any plans to visit the border
we've been to the border we've been to
the border you haven't been to the
border
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't understand the
point that you're making
well congrats to her for checking europe
off there but joe will she ever go to
the actual border and by the border i
mean the places that griff jenkins goes
bill malugen goes
oh you mean like la jolla or del rio uh
yeah you'll see that the same time you
see the detroit lions in the super bowl
who put up a good fight against the rams
yesterday by the way todd as you
probably saw look this is the
administration that is polling in the
20s in terms of its handling of the
border
absentee landlords kamala harris joe
biden who and the numbers back this up
by the way in terms of the record number
of migrant crossings that we're seeing
this year they have zero interest in
tackling this issue this is the look
like you're working administration when
you're actually barely working kambla
harris like you just pointed out has
never actually been to a border town and
that includes arizona by the way we're
we're seeing the biggest surge right now
joe biden apparently drove through el
paso in a motorcade 13 years ago and the
white house press secretary with a
straight face mind you says that counts
as a visit which is insulting to
anyone's intelligence over the age of
six so yep have fun in europe uh because
we have a crisis at the border we also
have a supply chain crisis going on
where you won't see the president or the
vice president or secretary pete
butterjudge visit a port city in los
angeles new jersey the gulf coast
savannah so again we have an
administration that is being outworked
at this point by people trying to solve
problems that don't have remotely the
amount of power that they do at this
point okay so we have to get to this uh
obviously president biden is facing some
falling poll numbers but even snl is
picking up on it let's take a watch at
this and we'll talk to you on the other
side
all right
your cnn town hall was watched by no one
and your approval rating is in the
dumpster
i don't understand
people used to like me
i miss the old me
where the hell did that guy go
hey wait a second who are you who am i
what do you mean who i'm you
i'm you from eight years ago man
the ghost of biden pass boom
how can you be me you seem so happy
sound
carefree
so so uh what's the word i'm looking for
luther
okay so other than hysterical like what
is your take on snl even throwing jabs
at the binding administration
actually i i wonder if we use the word
jabs there
this is as gentle as a butterfly landing
on a tulip in terms of the mocking of
joe biden but it does show you however
how far the president has fallen in
terms of polling you see zogby he's at
36 percent you see quinnipiac he's at 37
and we're only 10 months into the
administration and that's with very
favorable press coverage i'm actually
surprised there wasn't a staff walkout
over doing a skit that actually jabs at
joe biden meanwhile did you see the end
of the show i know i look at my age i
can't stay up that late but i i did see
the clips after performing for 90
minutes on stage without masks the fully
vaccinated cast they put their mask back
on talk about virtue signaling so that's
snl at this point they go after joe
biden kinda but it's not with the
vitriol that we saw with the former
president played by a guy who you know a
very tragic thing happened uh on that
set of rust with alec baldwin and i hate
the fact by the way that people on
online and on social media are somehow
using this to attack alec baldwin it was
a horrible thing that happened uh he
made a horrible accident mistake but
let's not start attacking people because
there is a woman that died here and i i
just uh want to end on that note and by
the way actually
yeah let's end on a happy note actually
that this fox weather app by the way
janice dean i'm sorry i'm looking at my
48 hour weather forecast here in jersey
i need noah's ark to get out of this
house at this point with all this rain
coming i wanted a happy app this is this
is this is very disturbing no it's
telling you the truth i mean you may not
like the truth
it's going to be rainy this week and
let's also focus on
a high note giants one joe koncha happy
weekend or happy week to you sir
thanks joe great win beating that third
string quarterback from carolina
congratulations no comment hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now